over anyway I'd rather Russians take it
over than fud of [__]
bangladeshis bro this is they can't do
this with our money disgusting and and
they're doing this knowing that the
Christians will not react France is a
Christian
country did you guys know the definition
of emergency is a serious situation that
requires immediate action imagine your
loved ones under Rubble in earthquake or
bombs being dropped in Gaza or in Yemen
or in Afghanistan where there's an
earthquake brother and sisters we're
working with one get immediate relief to
those who are in need please go to the
link and donate whatever you can
inshallah and let this be a that use for
your use there for your brothers and
sisters when they needed
youum brothers and sisters and dear
friends hope you guys are well inshah as
you guys know brothers and sisters
myself Muhammad hijab when it comes to
advising and bringing people you know
people who are new to Islam or those who
may have fallen short we try to defend
the honor to the best of ability why
because the Shar calls for it why
because they are a maybe a new Muslim
somebody who's made a mistake it's their
first mistake you know we don't throw
people under the bus we assume the best
in the Believers but at the same time
when the Sharia calls us to defend Islam
and call to account our brothers and
sisters whoever they are for that matter
we have to also do that this is why
Allah has told us in the Quran that let
there Rise amongst you a group of people
who will enjoying good and forbid evil
and this is something so so important in
our religion that the prophet wasam said
you either enjoying good and forbid evil
or that even if you prostrate and was
prostrated to Allah subhana tala it will
not be accepted from me and the matter
is very very severe now when it comes to
this issue obviously there was videoos
circulating and I saw obviously a lot of
people attack our brother Dilly not on
this matter like oh you know he didn't
mean this like we're talking about
Andrew Tate he didn't mean this he meant
in that way we've done I think we've
gone past the stages of good assumptions
in the sense where we've assumed he was
new Etc and believe me if it was a
Muslim sister who came to Islam and was
doing some of the things he's doing that
would be out that'll be outright outrage
outrage and again that's you know the
unconscious bias maybe a lot of people
have
but the point is what now he's come out
with his brother again people saying
it's parody it's just a joke why not let
the Russians take it over all the
immigrants have taken it over anyway I'd
rather Russians take it over than a
bunch of [__] bangladeshis come take
it every single day tens of thousands of
people every single month tens of
thousands of people are coming across
and just settling in England God knows
who they are Isis terrorists [__]
Mexicans Chinese everyone's just coming
in and invading our country pis yeah
well [__]
he's come and said the p word and the
nword and then he's having to go at
Bangladeshi I don't know what's a
problem with bang why why does everyone
have a problem with bangladeshis yeah
from k whatever his name is to Andrew
they have a beef of Bangladesh is I mean
you guys doing a phenomenal job for
everyone to be coming for you guys and
now Andrew tat is saying that he' rather
have the Russians rule over than
Bangladesh's really okay anyways where
is he coming from what is this issue
this is outright racism I mean I don't
care if you are yourself black I mean
imagine I'm Kurdish and I start
insulting Kurds what right I'm I'm still
racist just CU I'm a k doesn't mean I
cannot be racist oh you know it's
irrelevant to that point so he's coming
up with racism which is absolutely
disgusting and now he seems like he's
appealing to the far right of there
videos I've seen of him it's as if if I
Clos my eyes and you know didn't
recognize Andre's voice I think is Tommy
Robinson speaking you know the way he's
acting and behaving uh recently Subhan
Allah now to me from what I've seen in
him and assessing him closely and
speaking to people around me he seems
like a pure prag which is what he's
basically and he's mentioned this many
times you know Islam is pragmatic it
works this that our religion is not
based on what it works because if that's
the case you can have for example
Christianity come along the Route and
fix their ways of getting rid of this
lgbqt or whatever it is for that matter
and going back to the roots of
Christianity what's going to happen
you're going to change teams now you
know this is very interesting this is
this is the reason why some of the
scholars have said that why the Battle
of ohood obviously some say it was a
draw some say it was a loss why because
everybody wants to be on the winning
team and this was to test the Believers
and see you know because if every time
they winning a war people are going to
think oh I want to be in the winning
team that's why a lovef would do in the
Quran Allah mentions that so losing
these battles was what to show that who
is really there for the real reason and
who is not so what I'm seeing with
Andrew Tate recently is that I don't
think he truly understands the concept
who Allah is like he see he talks about
you know there's good and there's bad
and you know for every evil there that's
not the Allah we worship now this could
be again ignorance he doesn't know he's
been a Muslim for a year he has Muslims
around him but for some odd reason he
doesn't invite them but invites an
individual like Tommy Robinson the
scumback dirb back who cheats on his
wife every other week and SNS cocaine
yes and invites people like Katy Hopkins
who insult the prophet Muhammad peace be
upon him yes now why is this very
important because he went out on a
protest Andrew T went on a protest
openly and nobody's going to do anything
besides say oh the law says we need to
put you in jail for telling the truth
about God is this is is this who the
Christians of Romania have become I
think this is disgusting I don't think
this is good and I don't think Jesus
will smile upon this bro this is they
can't do this with our money this
disgusting and and they're doing this
knowing that the Christians will not
react France is a Christian country
anyone who believes in man woman
marriage child and God should be here as
well as upset as we are there's no need
for this this is absolute desecration of
Jesus Christ for no possible reason
other than to mock the fact that
Christians have become weak that's all
this is I say this as a Muslim man
because we respect Jesus Christ the same
which rightly so when it comes to Jesus
people insulting Jesus and mocking Jesus
that's our Prophet but you are the same
person who is inviting individuals who
are insulting your Prophet who is more
dear to us than our mothers and fathers
so I don't understand yes I don't I do
not understand this you are out
protesting with the risk of going back
to prison for three months to defend
Jesus rightly so we're fully behind you
cuz like you said in that video You're a
Muslim but then you are the same person
as under the same breath inviting
individuals who are insult ing your
Prophet now Andrew T I want to ask you a
question if somebody insulted your
mother or your father who is passed away
or not passed away and imagine I invite
them to my show and go oh you know
there's a bigger picture for that matter
they they're fighting The Matrix or
whatever would you accept that would you
say you know what oh you know Ali's goal
is bigger Etc no you will say what kind
of an individual are you that you are
inviting individuals who have been
swearing at my mother slandering my
mother and abusing her where is the the
the double standards and hypocrisy I
mean I don't know what's going on your
mind and I'll be honest with you I hope
and we try our best assume the best I'll
be honest with you it's really pushing
it now in the sense where genuinely we
need some Next Level Iman to assume the
best but you have a lot of Muslims
around you your friends who are around
you I do not know what's going on but I
just want to remind you that and I mean
this with all due respect Islam does not
need you I'll be very blunt at the point
Islam doesn't need me Islam doesn't need
muham hijab if every person turned their
back on Islam Islam does not need Allah
does not need none of us
we need Islam and we will inshallah
succeed with Islam so if your move is
pragmatic yes because you a chess player
if it's like you know I'm riding the
wave I don't know we don't know only
time will tell just know that Allah subh
says do not say that you're going to
believe and not be tested you was tested
it seem like you went through it yes and
you it seem like you came out well but
now the route that you are taken with
the far right it's very very dangerous
and if you're doing this because it's
all about you and again this is wrong
because Islam comes first and this Ayah
in the Quran which I'll read for you
guys in brother and sisters Allah says
in the
Quran Allah says in the Quran you will
not find a nation or people who believe
in Allah in the last day loving or being
friendly with anyone that opposes Allah
and his messenger even if they were
their fathers or their sons or their
brothers or their near relatives now I
don't want anyone to give me a cookie
for this but I was in a situation where
my family members are hostile towards
Islam yes our loyalty is with who Allah
and his messenger the truth not I know
this person or his I don't care BR I'm
not going to follow my forefathers cuz
they're my forefathers I don't care do
you get it we have respect I have utmost
respect to my dad to best him ability I
mean he said some stuff where if he was
somebody else you know God knows what
would happen but to me I have utmost
respect to my father however I will
never turn my back inshallah to my
religion and Islam and Allah has to
confess for you bro not oh Tommy
Robinson and Kat Hopkins are aiding me
and helping my cause nobody cares about
your cause bro your cause is the cause
that we're talking about it's Islam and
it's far greater and it's Eternal yes
your cause is finite and it's about you
and when you die it's going to die with
you focus on the cause that is greater
than you which is Allah subhana wa tala
and you will benefit in this life and
the Hereafter that's all I wanted to say
inshallah may Allah subh look I don't
have anything against you may Allah keep
you firm yeah I don't know what you're
going through I'm not there but again
please inviting the far right it's a
dangerous move that's all I want to say
if you're watching this I don't know if
you would but